the most memorable free falls of all
time not including chris sims falling to
round three back in 2003. you have the
trivia question for me i have not peaked
at it no advanced research i have no
idea what it is which means i'm
guaranteed to get it wrong but it's a
good one here it's got me thinking that
1996 was the last draft without a qb
taken in round one who was who was the
first qb taken in the draft by the rams
at pick 42.
tony banks way to go you're the man
way to go way to look at the computer
screen as soon as he took it off way to
go good job i have i'm telling you
i i admit when i inadvertently see it
i admit it i admit it uh tony banks that
was a good one there i forgot he was the
starter of that 2000 ravens team earlier
in that year
yeah well and he was with the rams until
the rams decided to go with trent green
right until trent greene tore his acl on
a hit from our colleague rodney harrison
in the 1999 pre-season and then dick
vermeel cried sad tears and eventually
cried happy tears thanks to the former
grocery bagger turned arena football
league turned nfl europe superstar kurt
warner uh just a man just amazed just
amazing they are making a movie of kurt
warner's life what the hell took them so
long seriously what a crazy ass story
that was a guy who was in the draft pool
in 94 undrafted all to talk about heath
schuler and trent dilfer kurt warner
undrafted in 1994 bounces around plays
for the iowa barnstormers the team that
had the goggles above the face mask on
their head awesome i love that i love
that but anyway what a story what a
story yeah it's amazing kurt warner okay
uh i get the first pick the all-time
draft day free falls it begins and ends
in many respects with oh aaron rodgers
24th overall in 2005
wanted to be the first overall pick that
year of the san francisco 49ers
offensive coordinator of the team
was mike mccarthy he goes on to become
the head coach in green bay awkwardness
for the entirety of the mccarthy rogers
relationship but yeah and just the video
and thank god they've gotten away from
sticking the camera in the face of the
guy who shows up at no fee no appearance
compensation there my god that's aaron
rodgers amazing holy crap but you know
constantly constantly sliding sliding
sliding all the way to the packers at
24. that is the most memorable draft day
free fall yeah it's it's a pretty good
one i can still remember sitting there
watching it you know because again i was
playing
you know i knew about aaron rodgers you
know in college i remember seeing him a
few times like you know just watching tv
and college games going like man that
guy looks like he can really throw it i
don't know and then you know again i'm
playing and i you know hear people in
the league oh rogers rogers rogers he's
going to be a top five pick blah blah
blah i mean i was there in tampa where i
i think we were tossing around the idea
of rogers as a top five pick that year
because we had a top five pick we took
cadillac williams so that was pretty
amazing and
you know the the rumor was always what
that the 49ers thought
you know alex smith they could control
him better than aaron rodgers he would
listen to every word they said where
rogers was a little of the outside the
box thinker so uh that that's that's
funny there all right well i'm gonna go
stay at the quarterback to me this is
the all-time free fall at
uh is dan marino dan marino that 1983
draft you know i think a lot of people
thought he was going to be maybe the
first the second quarterback off the
board behind john elway certainly going
to be a top five top ten pick you know
there was a lot of rumors i think out
there about maybe him being a partier at
pitt or whatever
nonetheless he falls so late in the
first round to a good team and the rest
is history with the miami dolphins and
he sets the league on fire as a rookie
and remember the steelers had a shot at
him yeah he didn't want to bring in a
quarterback they still had terry
bradshaw and we talked about earlier
this year
the old news story of bradshaw getting
elbow surgery in shreveport under the
name tom brady that's amazing and and oh
it's fun you know just like always
surgery was a success he's ahead of
schedule he'll be fine he played like
one more game through eight more passes
for the steelers and then no more terry
bradshaw so they would have really
benefited from keeping pittsburgh
product both growing up high school and
college in town and they didn't next one
for me 1998 randy moss
going into the draft was regarded as a
top five guy the cowboys had said we're
gonna draft you and the slide began and
it continued and i look i was full-blown
bleed purple vikings fan in 1998 and i
remember being very fearful being
resigned to the reality the bears were
going to take randy moss and this west
virginia guy was going to become a thorn
in the viking side for years to come so
as he slid and slid and slid and slid
uh i i remember
watching that thinking
there's no way he's making it to 21.
there's no way he's making it to 21. and
i think they sprinted unlike 2002 and
2003 when they blew it with the the
clock they sprinted to the podium when
they had the chance to take randy moss
at 21. yeah i mean that was a special
day i mean randy moss was an urban
legend already before that draft i mean
you already knew
like man
i've heard from a lot of people that
this guy's like the freakiest guy we've
ever seen and you know there was the
stories you know about him racing guys
in the parking lot at florida state him
beating everybody on the team and you
know of course he's not on their team
now and he's on marshall uh that was
amazing and of course he didn't
disappoint when he set foot in the nfl
all right i'm going to remember the
bobby bowden quote about randy moss i i
i don't remember exactly what what is it
he runs like a scalded dog that's the
bobby bowden club geez that's that's
great thank you um all right
let's go uh 1988 thurman thomas all
right one of the great running backs of
all time most people thought of course
he was going to be like a top 15 top 20
pick you know i think really higher than
that and there he is
falls out of the first round and falls
out of the first round really you know i
think a lot because
barry sanders was on his team at
oklahoma state and everyone kept going
wait that guy's so awesome and i'm not
sure how good this other guy is
well he was awesome too i mean
unbelievably awesome one of the best
dual threat running backs right past
game run game that we've ever seen in in
league history and really was one of the
best offensive players in the nfl for
about six years straight at least in
that conversation there with the buffalo
bills
next one for me and even though he was
still taken at number 12 he should have
been taken a lot earlier i'm looking at
the listing he probably should have been
number one that year the great warren
hall of famer 1995.
and the irony here
and i need to ask coach dungy about this
at some point
he was the defensive coordinator in
minnesota and they took derrick
alexander a defensive end who never did
much of anything in the nfl one pick
before the buccaneers got warren sapp
and dungey would become the head coach
of the buccaneers the next year there's
got to be a hell of a story as to why
the vikings didn't take warren sapp
remember the marijuana stuff came out
like like anyone would even give a crap
now 1995 oh no oh no he's oh no he's
possibly smoked marijuana and he falls
to number 12. i mean amazing yeah i
think most people looked at warren sapp
as a top three top five pick for sure
and yeah there was off the field he
might party too much type of crap out
there and yes i mean good thing
good thing i mean coach dungey's
probably happy he's probably like good
thing we passed him up there that helped
me you know my jump off to my career all
right i mean i think the last one i'm
going to go to is lamar jackson lamar
jackson pick 32 the whole night we sat
there going wait are the ravens going to
take him at 15 or 16 you know who's
going to take him what's going to happen
is he going to go in the top 10 then i
really resided to the fact like he's not
going to go in the first round he's
going to fall out we'll see you tomorrow
and then the ravens sweep in to get him
at 32. and of course they made the right
decision because he's been one of the
best players in the league
and they they moved around in round one
right they tend to drop out
and i i hey look steve bashady the owner
of the team and again we're learning
more and more how involved owners are he
was pushing middle of the round get him
get him get him get him and he's like
just
they knew what they were doing right
there was champagne popping when they
got lamar jackson at number 32.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports